again for a live alright so you don't
look everything just lit up all right
we'll give people a bit of time to come
in here for those of you who don't know
beer comedy I this is our open source
driving agent
[Music]
this isn't some fake stuff you can what
everything you see here is already
public you can just go download it this
is an eon you can buy another shop a
shop comic REI
it's very nice now of course since this
is a YouTube live we're about to show
you something that's that's not public
so maybe you guys will find it exciting
a little bit to the right and it'll
automatically change lanes
[Music]
so you see everything without a curve
showing laps see how it does lean change
on curve
you go downstream appeal I'll share the
wheel we got 15 people we got 15 people
do away for a few more people
demonstrating again walk and make a
u-turn
yeah but team on the seat a steering
wheel so how do you wanna see was doing
yeah so it's not it's it's automatic but
it requires you to look it doesn't know
when it's safe to make the lane change
that's your job as a person
[Music]
I'm gonna spin the car around up here
few years to live
I don't even think I think that I'm
gonna do to myself does that's how I've
always done in the past you don't have
to anymore a walks Harris asking to
blind spot monitors it's not linked to
the blind spot monitors yet so any of
the cars that can get them on we're
gonna add it in before their ships live
and for reference guys this is e07
feature so this you're gonna see a few
open pilot releases without this there's
more to this feature then than just Lane
changing but just Lane changing small we
go demonstrate for you guys today
watch the I don't know if you guys have
seen the full self-driving Tesla video
[Music]
foolish after having cast the video is
very inspiring and I think we'd like to
be Tesla to shipping all those things
[Music]
see what a ship full self-driving maybe
maybe some scope he's know what Tesla
promised you guys what a Tesla promise
this year no now it shouldn't be it
shouldn't be say yeah yeah it's very
alpha feature but if you guys watched my
maybe it doesn't say you can and we
should be able to use the blind spot
monitors on the Toyotas yeah sure it's
you all right it's still doing it yeah
we kind of any hacks to detect when the
lane changes over not so I know there's
some Forks with pilot lane changes um
this is not hacks this is trained on
probably a million lane changes that you
guys did in real life
[Music]
yeah yeah I think I've in order to make
this model it has watched you humans
users of all the violent do 100,000 lane
changes and that's how it learns to do
the perfect lane change for every
situation so yeah there's a secret input
to the model that we normally set it to
driving straight but when we do the lane
change we just ask the model to do a
lane change so there's a question how is
speed controlled during the lane change
so that we don't do anything special
with the with the speed but once it
starts doing the lane change deletes
switch
[Music]
here's a full blinker on gotta watch
that guy in my rearview ya little notch
little lunch automatically change I wish
we can I wish we could order in the
blinker oh yeah that would be nice yeah
so we could yeah we could keep doing it
oh we're back for that and then start
yeah now we'll cancel yes
yeah feels like it like costs that's the
beauty of neural networks though it's
all fuzzy
and you can make multiple languages just
give it one notch for this one change
lanes yeah you get one notch for this
one change lanes again yes at the
procedure she turned on the blinker and
then you get for the lodge when you
think it's clear and this is how we're
gonna proceed with a lot of these sort
of features right my experience with
navigator autopilot is that it increased
anxiety in a lot of ways because you
weren't sure when the car was gonna make
the lane change I'm sitting there and
I'm like from my perspective it looks
totally clear I have no idea why the car
isn't going I'm part of that gonna fix
of communication but part of that is you
want to be in control of your everyone
on some magic wand
everyone wants a wand that they can
weigh even like make the lane change
right but they don't want the wand to
tell them what wishes they want
no okay ideally it would monitor your
blind spot and tell you what it's safe
to go would you just have to press you
know engage Captain Picard but uh but I
kind of like the steering wheel to
acknowledge the engage it's like it's a
nice button yeah
[Music]
now this is not in the FEL right now
this is a very very early preview of cr7
there's going to be a bunch more sera
six releases first we've actually
stripped these weights out of the model
so good luck John ahead of yourself
there's a secret 512 dimensional vector
that will enable can I scroll back you
guys are killing it thanks guys I can't
see all the messages point seven
available on an ER near you yeah you
won't get this you'll be like man I wish
I bought a yard when they didn't run out
this the time of day affect the lane
change performance not children the way
it is things learned to change lanes by
watching all of your lanterns so if all
of your lane changes happen at all times
of the day yeah yeah and you have to
keep the blinker on
right now during the lane change but
that might change maybe it's like 15
yeah like everything is deep learning
[Music]
yeah this needs some work yeah we need a
better way to detect when the lane
change is down which it's done yeah now
we have some hacky way by looking at the
lane oh yeah I just yeah I guess that
was the problem I just thought it was
yeah
Lord speed here this should be and this
is an example of like people think open
pilot is only for the highway but this
guy off just because I guess beaten
people think about is only for the
highway it's not aiya works decently
well
yes yes ERISA text text stream command
to turn the blinkers on but that's like
a ferry debug a command and it stops
working when the car moves so maybe just
a different one but haven't found it
[Music]
yeah but then the stalk is still there
so I mean maybe if you put it in a debug
mode well it won't work anymore but no
I'm wondering is there a way to
electronically pop the stalk or is that
yeah I think it's mechanical yeah I mean
my parents new BMW it's just not
physical anymore so I just like a double
press talk
but Alexi sets its mechanic coma oh yeah
maybe that's the wrong it's like really
weird oh yeah well we're gonna make a
small detour it's weird like yeah have
some I made a mistake
I have to make like three right so any
more questions about the lane change 24
people I guess we didn't post on Twitter
well 24 people apparently yeah that was
nice about the scope East and everyone
got a notification oh it was way too
late so a while ago apparent you said
we're we're never gonna ship automatic
lane change and what changed all right
so you ever changed Tesla we're never
gonna ship stock science until Tesla
does all right so we're like you know we
use a waste of time to even think about
stop signs until Tesla's figured it out
right cuz maybe it's really hard and we
can let them figure out whether it's
really hard or not but they've already
figured out lane changes and it actually
turns out to be easy let's say oh look
at this a lane change through an
intersection see now what can do that if
only us
so we were never gonna ship adjustable
following distance can I say we were
never gonna ship automatic lane change I
don't know maybe you then it's not it's
it's it's um you do the lane jam it does
it for you but yeah I think we should
called assisted Lane choice I think
that's like much more regulated friendly
yeah Greg came up with that I like it
yeah yeah that's like automatic is that
a real thing or did like bar make that
up I think us are in a minute alright
thank yous gobies oh when it's the next
minecraft stream o.o stream tonight
actually I was thinking about dreaming
but maybe nap first of those dream not
well in craft um Hank alright